que vous y croyez vraiment
pour le moment
vous pouvez lancer un mec
a passé une interview qui a duré presque
deux heures c'était pas une interview
sur l'Égypte il y a eu une minute et 37
secondes sur l'Égypte pour donner un
exemple concernant l'Afrique je parlais
de l'Afrique avant de l'Union d'idées de
solidarité et j'ai donné un exemple les
pyramides parce que c'est fascinant
apparemment ils avaient l'électricité
c'est une théorie en fait c'est une
théorie qui existe depuis longtemps qui
est diffusée sur des sites dans des
vidéos sur des sites complotistes des
sites révisionnistes c'est pas vrai en
fait EDF parle de 2000 ans avec eux
avant Jésus
vous maintenez vous y croyez en vrai je
peux pas la fermer je peux pas vous
affirmer qu'il y avait des électricité
au sommet des pyramides etc moi je pense
que ça nous dépasse jusqu'au aujourd'hui
c'est un sujet mystérieux et moi j'aime
ce côté qui laisse place à l'imagination
qui disent ouais mais ça ça fait partie
des théories complotistes etc il a dit
c'est un artiste mais bien sûr il
marchera avec Sonia Salamé et puis je
remarque qu'il y en a encore la ministre
de la Culture qui travaille énormément
je l'ai trouvé très sympa maître Gims
ils l'ont fait passer pour un
complotiste pour un mec qui disait
n'importe quoi il en avait fait des
blagues il a tué non non non
c'était genre ouais on rigole c'est bon
c'est bon allez c'est bon c'est bon moi
je l'ai trouvé sympa de répondre à la
question et je trouve qu'il a remix de
milieu du village voilà moi je suis un
article je suis un chanteur parfois je
dis des conneries mais son job je suis
désolé exactement de chanter il est pas
étonné
du crédit à ça le mec effectivement il a
fait une interview de 2h tu as 30
secondes sur l'Égypte que ça c'est
insupportable
comment était interrogé sur une autre
polémique celle où il demandait aux
musulmans de ne plus lui souhaiter la
bonne année ça c'est autre chose voilà
ça pour moi
ça c'était une connerie mais là c'est
encore les théories complotistes etc
c'est encore je vous dis ça ça voilà
c'est c'est voilà c'est c'est incroyable
c'est la télé que je vous dis je l'aime
bien mais c'est la télé que je peux pas
voir je suis désolé oui oui mais c'est
la télé que je veux pas voir
c'est la télé des donneurs de leçons on
n'en peux plus exactement
c'est insupportable c'est insupportable
ça existe
moi ma mère est chrétienne mon père est
chrétien donc ils sont dans Noël ils
sont dans tout ça donc je suis
indirectement c'est eux aussi qui sont
choqués de mes propos les les premiers
on va dire j'aurais pas dû faire cette
vidéo franchement même le look et tout
comment je suis casquette Chanel
Rolls Royce désolé non c'était pas bon
c'est pas bon la combinaison le timing
n'était pas bon il est effacé je voulais
effacer mais
c'était parti c'était un million il va y
avoir des erreurs bien sûr j'essaie de
d'en faire le moins possible je sais que
je suis un haut-parleur qu'on écoute et
ça c'est des trucs j'arrive pas à
assimiler tout le temps parce que je
suis quelqu'un de tellement je suis
moi-même quoi je suis le ministre c'est
très bien bravo bravo
c'était marrant et voilà donc en fait
elle pouvait rien faire parce qu'après
mais la miniature n'a pas réagi naturel
du tout ni sur les pyramides ni sur ce
qu'il a été très bien voilà mais c'est
très sympathique
je t'emmerde moi j'aime le mystère j'ai
envie de voilà
j'ai envie de laver j'ai envie d'y
croire essayer de l'amener ils ont
essayé de l'amener voilà sur les
théories qu'on peut aussi tout ça il
aura dit voilà je sais pas ça c'est très
visionniste exactement mais c'est
toujours comme ça je vais te dire dès
que tu dis un truc aujourd'hui c'est ça
c'est fort tu vas dire j'ai pas attaché
mes lacets on va dire c'est comme ici
c'est quand même compliqué
ça n'a rien à voir
très connu qui ont relayé ses heures
ne comparez pas le 11 septembre on
compare pas un drame à ce que vient de
dire déjà c'est c'est mal venu justement
la même chose c'est exactement grave et
là on veut mettre dans la merde on va
encore cancer un mec qui a fait une
grosse carrière on veut lui [__] sa
carrière il a dit une fois interview
arrive
le traité avec humour
Daniel chérie non mais révisionnistes
c'est quand même un mot très très grave
bien sûr c'est vrai que dans l'ensemble
et surtout Gims a été génial il s'est
défendu très de personnes il sait très
bien défendu en revanche excuse-moi qui
est peut-être moi j'adore aussi les
mystères et l'Egypte ça ne fait que de
ça et c'est pour ça que ça nous fait
donc il pose des questions
décompose une question qui va pas dans
le sens du vent on est content à la mode
donc voilà excuse-moi mais
bien sûr
on a le droit de s'interroger il dit
lui-même d'ailleurs je ne donne pas de
leçon lui contrairement à aller à Salamé
il dit moi je ne sais pas j'ai non ça il
y a un mystère et en tant qu'artiste
j'ai le droit de m'exprimer donc je dis
bravo Gims et c'est bien que des gens
posent des questions mais oui Valérie
vous regardez avec un moqueur parce que
vous balayez les opinions des autres bah
si moi je l'ai adoré maître Gims là je
sais pas mais j'ai trouvé très drôle
déjà il a rien à [__] samedi soir déjà
c'est la tristesse très drôle mais en
revanche dites pas que l'interview a été
en train de
regarder quelle époque non mais c'est
vrai ça a pour but de le ridiculiser
vous savez très bien Valérie voilà
et d'ailleurs il est invité d'ailleurs
il est il était bon il est en promo et
cetera mais maintenant on invite les
gens parce qu'il sait faire une
polémique enfin ils auraient plus
c'est le principe de
le mec il a il a il a il cartonne il est
sur un album et cetera oui là moi après
voilà
du truc mais bon vous auriez elle est la
tisé toutes les missions sur ça elle a
fait on va parler des pyramides et le le
l'intitulé c'était explication de texte
sous-entendu il va s'expliquer que sur
les polémiques respectez-le le mec déjà
il vous fait l'honneur de vous donner
l'heure et de venir sur le plateau c'est
c'est n'importe quoi
non c'est pas des sujets assez grave
pour qu'on en fasse autant je pense
qu'on s'en fout de royalement merci
c'est moi qui passe machine arrière et
qui se rendent pas sur le moi ça m'a
plus gêné la bonne année voilà
c'est de vendre des disques quand même
donc on fait machine arrière sur la
bonne année le truc du chat là du gros
chat du Sphinx là c'est un moment donné
il faudra qu'il fasse aussi sur des
trucs comme ça ils se rend compte tout
doucement qu'il faut qu'il fasse machine
arrière sur terre c'est vrai que c'était
pas bien il a dit